hi I'm Fergus early product manager at
Google I'm gonna show you how to use
Android vials to keep an eye on your
apps engineering performance metrics so
you can fix any problems that may affect
your users what is it important to track
your engineering metrics because when
your app performs badly users notice in
fact almost half of one-star review on
the Play Store mention performance
issues like app stability on the other
hand when things are running smoothly
users are happy Android voice tracks the
metrics that matter most your users
battery use stability rendering startup
time and permission requests let's start
with batteries because probably the most
important of all nobody wants to use nap
the trains are battery so Android
violence reports on the four most
significant causes of battery drain
wakelocks wake-ups background Wi-Fi
scans and background network use
background partial wakelocks
or when your app keeps the CPU running
after the devices display turns off it
can become stuck if it's held for a long
time while your app runs in the
background this can drain the users
battery so you should use them sparingly
and release them as soon as possible
the second cause of battery drain is
excessive wake-ups these let your app
wake up a device at a certain time bring
it out of low-power mode and holding a
partial wake lock while the alarm
executes again these can drain your
users battery and you want to use them
as lil as possible the last two battery
related metrics we track our excessive
background Wi-Fi scans and network use
in both cases your app connects to the
Internet in the background waking up the
CPU and turning on the radio which is
draining the users battery if your app
doesn't use any of these features then
you will not see metrics in vials for
them also if your app does not have
enough users above the privacy threshold
then you will not see any data either so
now that we've covered battery life the
next most important area of Android
vials to focus on is app stability we
track to stability metrics in or events
and crashes
application not responding RA in or
events or when your app stops funding to
user input this happens when the UI
thread of the app is blocked for too
long so the user app appears to freeze
on them crashes occur when an unhandled
exception our signal cause your app to
exit unexpectedly of course you want to
keep both of these to a minimum your
Android boils dashboard also displays
your apps rendering metrics use one a
fast responsive application that runs
smoothly and doesn't lie or stall so we
track any instances of slow rendering
our frozen frames slow rendering is when
your app can't render frames in under 16
milliseconds when this happens your app
appears to stutter
we call it jank frozen frames occur when
you iframes
take longer than 700 milliseconds to
render this makes your app appear stuck
and unresponsive to user input for
almost a second users also expect your
app to launch quickly on your Android
viols dashboard you can easily identify
it when your app is loading slowly with
different metrics for cold starts warm
starts and hot starts a cool start is
when your app hasn't been launched for a
while and isn't in the devices memory
this means the device needs to create
and start all your apps resources to get
it running in this case a slow start
would mean five seconds or more a warm
start is when your app is in memory and
it simply needs to go from activity
launched activity running in this case a
slow start would be two seconds or more
finally a hot start is when your app and
its activity are in memory your app goes
from honoré start to activity running
from a hot start yaahh
shouldn't take longer than 1.5 seconds
to load the last metric in your
dashboard is all about permissions here
you'll see the percentage of people who
denied a permission request made by your
app if the level is high you may need to
explain the reason for your request or
rethink whether you actually need that
permission at all so how do you know if
your metrics are good on the dashboard
you'll see benchmarks for each file to
help you understand how your app our
game is performing and which issues if
any to prioritize for example people
expect board games to load faster than
racing games so your metrics will only
be measured against similar apps not
sure what focused on first well although
your metrics are important to monitor
we've highlighted the four most
important ones on your Android vayas
dashboard ARH
crash rate stock wakelocks in the
background and excessive wake-ups we
call these the core vials
hopefully your apps metrics all look
good but if something should go wrong
it's important to fix problem as quickly
as possible
that's why Android vials also provides
anomaly detection just click on the
dashboard alert to learn more about the
problem or you can sign up for anomaly
alerts emails
addressing these issues as quickly as
possible not only keeps your users happy
it also helps improve your apps profile
in the Play Store such as its
discoverability in the search results
android vitals gives you the tools to
monitor your apps performance and keep
it running smoothly for more advice on
how to address app use check out our
videos on stability and battery life
you'll find the links in the video
description to learn more about Android
files the rest of the play console are
for tips on how to grow your app our
game business
check out the playbook app on Google
Play thanks for watching